[Música]
vou fazer eu não percebo nada de
botânica
mas tanto quando sai às raízes são uma
parte do subsídio dependente das plantas
estão lá embaixo da terra açúcar água e
outros recursos
enquanto a parte importante da planta
está do lado de fora
a contribuir para a economia com frutos
flores em madeira não convidaram
fotônica convidaram pra falar do riso
forma metafórica reis no sentido de
origem como local onde nash e faz
sentido que se chama em guimarães os
clubes aí foi aqui que nasceu portugal
não é motivo de orgulho de todos os
países que poderiam ter nascido a partir
de guimarães um país que tem que estar
sempre a ser resgatada pelo fmi não é
grande coisa
portanto os vimaranenses orgulham se
algo que os livros ganharam estivéssemos
a falar de um país grandioso e como a
economia pujante como ao maior china
tudo bem
foi só portugal muitas vezes as pessoas
falam do regresso às raízes como algo
bom como regressar ao puro e original
não é bom
o progresso fácil pra frente para o topo
e nunca em direção à terra que é onde
estão as raízes
foi assim em portugal incluiu começou
aqui em guimarães e dirigiu se para sul
até chegar à parte importante e bonita
que a lisboa o regresso às raízes no
fundo é o regresso ao passado
ele estará a passar nunca é bom porque
foi no passado aconteceram as maiores
tragédias da humanidade remoto 1755
holocausto o governo do engenheiro
sócrates
os concertos do tony carreira no
pavilhão atlântico no futuro não
aconteceu uma única tragédia
e é por isso que é para lá que nos
devemos dirigir
ora o voltar às raízes é perigoso em
qualquer circunstância pensa e como é
que pensamos em risco
pensamos em momentos de desespero por
exemplo foram vítimas do naufrágio e
qualificar os presos numa ilha deserta o
que pensamos
bom agora pra comer só temos golfinhos e
raízes golfinhos porque é uma
oportunidade única não há ninguém para
julgar e é isso
quando acabarem os golfinhos
o que quer dizer que voltar às raízes
vai implicar que uma pessoa mais dia
menos dia tenha terminar todos os
golfinhos
eu queria contar os agora a história de
um amigo tentou regressar acho que isso
não fosse a minha intervenção
eu teria ficado enterrado vivo para
sempre ora este amigo era uma pessoa de
sucesso anunciou ela herdou a sua
empresa e fazia parte de um grande grupo
económico e certo dia eu phantons de
rompante diz apenas que fazer isto
significa nada
vou embora e foi muito constrangedor
porque foi mais uma toca eu tenho um
microfone e gravata o fato e sem o dono
do auditório as pessoas levantaram sapo
ao ver algumas estavam chorar sentiam-se
inspiradas por que virão aqui o espírito
fato como um espírito de conceitos e
esse espírito preconceitos implica quem
credita à inovação e inovação não
residem palestras dentro do auditório e
fora daqui e laboratórios e escritórios
isso porque as pessoas viram o que eu vi
foi estupidez estupidez não me inspira
eu vi que meu amigo estava com problemas
e uma pessoa neste momento novo andou
nos seus amigos principalmente se for um
amigo em cuja empresa eu tinha dinheiro
investido em ações
eu tenho dito que eu nunca vi improvisar
uma toca nem toda a gente tem a
capacidade de improvisar como eu que é
precisamente isso que estou fazendo
agora
e então eu fui atrás dele foi encontrado
na casa de banho alinhavam no chão costa
turno e disse doutor sua palestra a
cerca sem teste de doping como estímulo
à criatividade na startup estava certo
em santo que sou eu diz o doutor isso
não significa nada nós somos tão
pequenos quando comparados com a
grandeza do universo bom falta ou se
eles não doutores não significa
absolutamente nada uma pessoa trabalha
vias de após vias falsa trabalhar e foi
esperta que o que é mais importante o
que é mais importante é não sair mas é
isso que eu quero descobrir é por isso
que eu tenho de regressar às raízes em
si uma casa do bairro quando as pessoas
estavam todas a porta ao seu torno e eu
sei e seguir festivo e eu tenho que
explicar uma uma aquelas pessoas que eu
não tinha feito um gol fácil que é o que
acontece nestas alturas em casas de
banho públicas ora desapareceu mas no
dia a seguir recebiam que o cinema era o
painel estava extremamente preocupado eu
mesmo doutor nem acredita no que
aconteceu
meu filho chegou ontem à casa e diz que
quer ser tratado como um bebê diz que
quer voltar a viver essa experiência
porque na altura não se lembra de nada e
minha mulher está trancada no quarto o
que está com medo que eu invado a outro
ora eu eu
é possível um estouro de uma empresa do
psi 20 a crescer é tratado como um bebê
os bebês precisam que as mães façam tudo
os homens de sucesso não precisamos que
haja mais nos façam tudo é para isso
temos escritórios estagiários
então eu fui pra casa ver o que se
passava em destruir tudo o que os
cliques crescer tratado como um bebê de
um nulo dada aqui vi que o caso era mais
grave
então fiz o normal dar uma chapada
porque 5x resolvem todos os problemas de
doença mental e aí resultou em uma
terapia porque respondemos como uma
pessoa normal disse o doutor eu tenho um
dia terrível área faltou ao trabalho
eu tive de tirar um café sozinho e quem
mais me fez do ivaí a menina
ora este show fora de mim
como é possível isto ter acontecido como
é que é possível uma pessoa com tantas
responsabilidades ter passado um dia ser
uma secretária
é claro que o que ser tratado como um
bebê sempre os desamparados coelhinha e
o que eu fiz logo a seguir foi o que eu
liguei para a empresa e obriguei a
contratarem uma nova secretária da sasc
teve de cantar canções de embalar por
acalmar um pouquinho troquei fralda e
convenceu a regressar à empresa tanto
quando saí porto vai a nova secretária
nunca mais faltou e não tivemos uma
perda terrível que era mais um sem o
outro portugal e portanto uma história
política acabar numa tragédia teve um
final feliz como intervenção é normal
num mundo complexo cheia de inseguranças
e situações imprevisíveis
as pessoas queiram regressar às raízes é
normal que em momentos de desespero com
primeiro emprego ou passar um dia sem
secretária
queremos voltar a uma zona de conforto
quer seja sermos tratados como um bebê
ou estarmos num candidato como prometa
que o nosso país vai ser grande outra
vez
este é o problema maior se passa por
esse mundo fora com a ascensão dos
populismos e dos movimentos
nacionalistas a um grupo de pessoas
obcecado por suas raízes e querem
conduzirmos para debaixo da terra para o
obscurantismo ou não há luz e oxigênio
a democracia os movimentos nacionalistas
são o maior perigo do retorno às raízes
em ser nacionalista é como ter um bebê
mas do ponto de vista biológico e tal
como os mexe os nacionalistas usam a
cabeça rapada sentem semsur gritam muito
alto que era uma figura da autoridade
que os proteja e muitas vezes chegam a
cocó com duas diferenças com duas
diferenças no caso do bb o cheiro e cocó
vem da fralda dos nacionalismos vem
dentro deus
a segunda diferença é que os bebês não
votou em ser nacionalista é um disparate
porque nós não escolhemos o país ao não
mexemos acho que se eu pudesse escolher
um trecho do livro portugal parecer por
ter um estilo em portugal as minhas
ambições tão limitadas
eu só poderei ser primeiro ministro de
portugal o presidente da comissão
europeia
nunca poderei ser chance de levar o
maior presidente estados unidos da
américa e mesmo em portugal as minhas
ambições tão limitado em si mas por não
ter mexido na família doutor helmi das
vezes nunca poderei ser presidente o
continente
é por isso que eu costumo dizer que é
uma parvoíce tremenda uma pessoa sentir
orgulho do cinto nas sobretudo sentido
superior por mexer ou não mexeu e os
movimentos nacionalistas de populismo e
é precisamente um dos maiores perigos e
o proveito
já estou em guimarães vão lançar um
motel para que vocês abandonei o vosso
lema do abc berço espiritual enquanto
não abandonarem o passado nunca poderão
abraçar o futuro daí tenha baixo voz
castelo
lembras o doutor ronald regan amplo o
doutor garantia para deitar abaixo o
muro de berlim para poder derrotar o
comunismo
eu estou aqui lançar uma pergunta vocês
deitarem abaixo os castelo para poderem
mandar abaixo o vosso passado
os vimaranenses têm orgulho imenso no
castel assim como sou mais leste tenham
orgulho imenso no seu muro que esperava
do capitalismo
infelizmente o muro vai abaixo e o que
se viu no mercado livre não era uma
ameaça era uma oportunidade da item foi
fora e peguem no batel para destruir o
nosso castelo
faça isso no próximo coffee-break
estiverem muito ligados emocionalmente o
castel peçam aos vossos amigos braga os
fazem espantoso
[Aplausos]
e é sempre rabo e regressar às raízes
não não é sempre rasgo estará isso
devemos ajustar as raízes sempre que for
rentável
portugal tem uma economia que dependo do
turismo certo em seus turistas têm a
expectativa de vir a portugal muito para
onde vai com expectativas nos verem a
ser os portugueses a autenticidade e
resgatar as raízes vendem tanto os
turistas vêm com perspectiva ter uma
experiência baseada em algo genuíno e
nós temos de ir ao encontro dos
estereótipos que eu sei nós temos uns
querem ver com barreto campino
o vestido como doutor em barreiros temos
de lhes proporcionar essa experiência
com a vinda dos turistas portugal tornou
se num parque temático e português se
tornar nosso que é animador de turistas
e portanto é se os turistas querem
sentir questão pessoal
devemos esforçar-nos por parceiros
portugueses e é curioso que seja preciso
virem pessoas de fora para nos forçar em
sermos nós próprios
portanto regressem às raízes trabalhar
em animação turística
segundo as duas novas cinco cinza não
perceberam que as raízes nos fazem pior
do que vai eu queria fazer uma
experiência convosco para terminar e só
se importam liguem os lusos flor que
incluirá todos fraco vantagem
muito vai agora coloquem a vossa mão
direita no bolso das calças para as
senhoras que estão saio legs obra o
flash meteu a mão dentro da nossa roupa
interior para poderem participar a não
sentirem excluídas e agora façam de
conta que não consegue lhe tenha mão
presa ela não consegue evitar que
começamos em havana há muito não façam
isso não conseguem mesmo enquanto estou
a fazer isto continue continue enquanto
estou a fazer isto olhem passo que
estava voz suave o que acho que essa
pessoa está a pensar está a pensar que
você estão agarrados às nossas raízes já
não tem na presidência e sabem que mais
enquanto não vamos nem as vossas raízes
enquanto não libertarem a vossa mão não
vou poder abraçar o futuro sobretudo só
de serem segmento alguém que pede para
colocarem as mãos nas vossas raízes não
fizerem por vocês
pelo menos façam pelos golfinhos muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]